good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast and
ha hum oh no that's my friday one yep
sorry [ __ ] good morning welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day
we're so excited to be back in studio
with theo on hump day
celebrating the art of humping the art
of humping the art of getting over the
hump which is what we're here to do
today because you know once today's show
is over
then we're closer to thursday and we're
just crawling towards that weekend y'all
and now would be a good time to let
everyone know that there is no show on
friday
because it's a summer friday i have a
bachelorette party and we
are going to town woohoo i'm really
excited about this weekend i haven't had
like a
girly girl weekend girly girl weekend in
a while so it's gonna be really fun
i have them all the time and i just have
to say like you're gonna have the best
time no i'm
really quite looking forward to it so
thank you so much so that like i might
even crash
yeah you never know what could happen on
a girly girl weekend i mean i have you
know last minute business trip to take
on thursday which was perfect timing for
you needing to take friday off but um
we're just
i can't stress this enough we're living
in a post-pandemic world
do not look for me i cannot be found
right but pre or post or
during pandemic like it's a summer
friday and we're going to make the most
of it
i also have a friend made the decision
so last year we took the month of august
off which we loved so much and then this
year we were toying with the idea of
doing that again
but instead we decided to keep august
normal but then like
feel free to take sporadic days here and
there so you'll be getting shows in
august unlike last year but we're just
gonna
use some of our pto yeah i'm gonna make
my schedule flexible
yeah very flexible summer schedule so
happy hump day to you
i'm having a day oh please share a
cleveland day
a cleveland day i just have to share and
it doesn't seem like a big deal but
like i'm such a principled person and i
follow the law
so i was just like i had such an
annoying morning like i decided to walk
here which is never a good decision but
it's gorgeous out
65 light breeze between my thighs feels
great
and okay so and i believe this is how it
is
in literally every state in america but
i'm not fully equipped on the traffic
laws in other states
so i was crossing the street i had the
little walking man
okay and the avenue running
perpendicular no no running parallel to
me
was also going down because that's how
it works i walk you walk we're parallel
somebody from the avenue went to make a
right onto the street that i was
currently crossing
i still have the right of way correct as
a pedestrian
so i'm running my own business listening
to last train home by john mayer across
the street
when this big [ __ ] bronco honks at me
and like first of all it's very
disarming to hear a honk like when
you're standing right in front of the
car it's so loud and just like
hits you in the middle of your chest not
only did i get honked incorrectly so i
look at him and i'm like what
because like i needed i wanted to give
him a second to realize he was wrong i
had the [ __ ] right of way
he doubled down and i could have just
kept ignoring it because he wasn't going
to run me over he was just standing in
front of me [ __ ] honking
but i just you know when something a
switch goes off hundred percent and i
got so [ __ ] angry
literally i went i bent like i squatted
in front of the car and i'm like
let me move my microphone back stop
honking
why why did you need to squat because i
wanted to look him eye level i was
standing he was sitting in the car
you know what i mean is it a low car
kind of
whatever you're getting hooked on the
wrong [ __ ] piece of information okay
okay no i just gotta put my hands on my
knees just to like give some
um you know okay so like stop honking
and he's pointing to the little man
walking like as if he's trying to show
me i'm wrong
and i'm like what are you i wanted him
to get out and just go tit-for-tat like
what are you trying to say with these
honks because i'm correct i have the
right of way i understand pedestrian
laws
you don't and i had bed in the back of
my head because i always take things to
the next level and ben's like why are
you fighting with a strange man
in a bronco but like i know and also
like people can be crazy like
you think that you're crazy but like
you're actually i don't carry a knife
like
there are actual crazy people a hundred
percent but like it was just the
principle was bothering me so much
because i was right
no that's so frustrating and don't drive
in new york if you don't understand the
laws and then start yelling at people
when you're the one who's wrong
no and also like reserve your honks for
like other vehicles not for passengers
like nobody really what could have
what could a pedestrian not passenger
what could a potentially
be doing that's so horrible you need to
ruin their day with the honk in their
ear like it's
so loud and also maybe we should
normalize lowering the sound of honks in
vehicles that's just like a thought
i completely agree because first of all
the only people that honks really are
for
are for other cars and they just ignore
you so like it doesn't matter how loud
it is
yeah but like when that honk when you're
standing right outside a car and someone
honks like you feel it in your butthole
like it's
so loud and if you don't if you're not
expecting it it's so disarming
it's so sick and twisted and i really
just wanted to get out and have a
conversation with this man because i
wanted to know what he was trying to say
he pointed to the walking side yes i
know i'm walking therefore the sign says
walking so i don't know what he was
trying to prove and i just i screamed
like all these people were staring at me
and i didn't care because i was [ __ ]
right no
and i had theo you think theo wants to
hear that [ __ ] hunk like he's he's a
very peaceful person
that's so upsetting that would have
really bothered me i would have already
been on zillow like
searching cleveland homes four bedrooms
it bothered me
so much like and i honestly thought
about following him just
i was actually curious curious at this
point what is your
point here what were you trying to say
with your hunk and your point
i don't know that's upsetting because
unless i've been
following the laws completely wrong my
entire life when the man is
white it's a little white man and he's
walking you walk yeah
explain make him except it doesn't say
honk no no and it doesn't say stop
there's that
red hand that comes up but the little
white lights pop up and it's a little
man
so i was following the little man it
does not say rsvp on the statue of
liberty thank you
so i just wanted to share that because
like i'm really like i i wanted to kill
someone
yeah i'm really sorry that that happened
to you not a good way to start your day
especially not a hump day no and like i
was feeling good about the day like i
had such a productive day yesterday i
have such a productive i have so many
things to do before
i have like meetings and like
appointments to do before i have to take
my business trip do you have meetings
meetings meetings i actually have
meetings meetings not
meeting speaking meetings i have
meetings meetings today too um which is
not why i'm wearing a [ __ ] bow
but i killed her i feel prepared to take
on the meeting but it's not
not why you're wearing a [ __ ] no no and
now i feel like i need to book some more
meetings
while i'm wearing this look i'll have my
people call your people yeah let's
just start meeting today love meeting
people constantly that's so you
i'm such a meter oh speaking of
meats i don't know um we have the meats
i went to such a good dinner last night
at a place that you would like and for
the one reason i didn't love it
i liked it a lot but i didn't love it
it's the reason like you might like it
because it wouldn't affect you
share i went to 12 chairs in west
village you're so cool
i know it's so far downtown celebrating
my father-in-law's birthday happy
birthday bruce
and spruce on the loose bruce on
long-lost did you send him happy
birthday text
no but is it today it was yesterday you
didn't tell me
that's true i didn't tell you i didn't
tell you but you should send a text
today um
so it was it's israeli food they played
like such good israeli music like i
actually went on spotify looking for the
playlist because it was just like all
the israeli bops that i needed to hear
um and it was packed and it was like
vibrant you know pre-pandemic
popping tables close together and the
food like i actually never ate so much
in my life and i hate falafel i had four
like it was just so good
but they only served beer and wine so
like there was just like a limitation on
how much fun i could have at this
restaurant
i think in the end i actually actually
ended up being really grateful for it
because i had to go to an event
afterwards and like i just didn't
end up getting wasted and like now i
feel good but if i drink at dinner like
i probably would have stayed out till
4am 100
um but like if i want to return to that
restaurant on a saturday night like i'm
not gonna go all the way downtown to
drink beer and wine
i think beer and wine is underrated like
remember camp toast like and
and it's having just beer in mind like
stops you from ruining your night okay
beard
i'm actually reading malibu rising right
now and i think that's the case that
nina's trying to make but obviously
that doesn't work out beer and wine in
certain circumstances at camp toast when
you wake up and literally start drinking
at noon and you don't go to bed till
four in the morning
we did it for the safety of the campers
like because if they were drinking
tequila and vodka like
the campgrounds would be covered in
vomit and like diarrhea like that was
for the safety of the grounds and for
the safety of the campers
yeah when you go to a two-hour dinner
like on a saturday night and you
for me i traveled so far downtown like i
want a margarita like
i understand but like i think it's a
nice like way to protect yourself and
like look at you today it's a hump day
you're here like you have so much to
give it's true and i want to thank this
restaurant 12
chairs yeah i just um for delivering her
whole
so yeah if people always ask for
restaurant recommendations and that is
going to be on my list but keep in mind
it's beer and wine and then i'm like all
right i'll have a bud light
we're all out all right i'll have a
corona we're all out so i had to get an
ipa that looked like an angry orchard
and it was so disgusting like i couldn't
drink it you're
so not an ipa girly like literally if
there is a picture of someone who's the
antithesis of just like all that ipa has
to stand for
it's me and you know why that is because
ipa
is for other girls and we've come to the
conclusion most recently that i
am not like other girls no not at all
not at all we have such a good show for
you guys today you guys
we have such a good show for you guys
today you guys
you guys and we have no tv recap because
for some reason the real housewives of
new york wasn't on last night and i
really just wanted to thank
andy cohen and everyone involved for
sparing me like watching an hour of that
like i wanted intolerable like drunk old
women i want to thank everyone who
contributed to that decision it was one
of the best
i don't even need a reason like i really
really don't um but we do have your
toasters because it's wednesday so
that's served by segment at the end of
the show
and i'm excited because we have an
update and two new submissions yeah we
have some
we have some good stories today have you
on the biz news i think you're gonna i
think you're gonna like this business i
mean it's appropriate that we have
business since we're in
meetings meetings meetings all day well
for me meetings meetings
yeah meetings meetings safe eyebrow
appointment meetings
do you have one yeah i need one you want
to come yes yeah
i was going to book one today because i
got a unibrow you know it's just like
it's that time when you go from looking
like cara delevingne to frida kahlo like
it's a
very very transitional time
and one day you wake up your car jelly
bean and the next day you're free to
call for me
because i have light or eyebrows i don't
like have
that but what i do start to look like is
you know the scene in beauty and the
beast
when dan stevens transitions from being
a man to a beast
and his eyebrows start to get like take
over his whole face
that's if you watch the scene maybe i'll
post i think maybe you've seen that
movie one too many times because that's
very detailed i have seen it probably
the same amount of time as you but like
when i saw what was happening to his
eyebrows i was like
oh that's me a month a month post wax
honestly i haven't seen beauty in the
beast in a while i think i'm due for my
viewing
i recently watched it because i was
hanging out with kayla and
it was so [ __ ] good did she like it
she loved it and you know she's a woman
of taste because she had no time for the
murray scenes
oh nobody does nobody does did you watch
a cartoon and this is actually the
perfect segue into our first story
but i want a version of beauty and the
beast maurice free
yeah belle's dad was kind of like
deadbeat almost like get a real job stop
making
like trinkets in your basement and i
just think he was constantly giving bell
bad advice and also
belle obviously didn't love him because
she should run a brush through his hair
i [ __ ] love beauty and beats like i
could analyze like all the different
facets of it i love it so much but okay
let's get into the fast side because our
first story is something that's going to
excite you so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and yes you've all broken my spirit you
broke me
[Laughter]
tonight's episode is brought to you i'll
give you one guess
oh she has to get it in somewhere bruce
is the best electric toothbrush on the
market
and if you're not gonna listen to me
listen to literally the thousands of
toasters who have purchased one for them
their partners their husbands their
sisters their boyfriends their brothers
it is the best electric toothbrush on
the market it is sleek it is elegant and
it works
so well the brush itself or should i say
the brush
comes with six six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
it has a four week battery life a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head again
the design is very sleek the brush's
electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design
it comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter
all the toasters are brushing with brush
and so are we we've been doing it
for like a year and my teeth are
literally stunning so if you want teeth
as
stunning as mine get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and refill plan when you
use the promo code toesteprouch.com
that's 15 off promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com love it sign on bruce your teeth
first story a snow white live action
remake
is coming starring rachel zegler who i'm
sure you do not know but she is set to
star as maria
in the upcoming west side story remake
which was supposed to come out already
but now is moved to december because of
kovid
and then she'll be starring in suno
white live so we're about to be seeing a
lot of rachel
so i heard about this story briefly
because their
report came out that disney had very
serious conversations with olivia
rodrigo
to be snow white in this live action
which i think she's too busy to do right
now but i think that would have been
cool would have been amazing
yeah but you know what i feel like i'm
such a disney girl and like maybe my
mind will change because i haven't seen
snow white in so long
i'm not really connected to the story of
snow white you know what i mean like
i don't live for for it and maybe i just
haven't seen it in a while and i need
like disney live action to
recreate like the magic but i don't know
i just don't feel very
connected to her story i i feel that and
i do feel more connected to the story of
the huntsman for sure
by the way and tell me the difference
between this live action and then the
two other movies they made of snow white
snow white and the huntsman was like an
action game of thrones style version
that really focused on the huntsman and
they were like getting into trouble and
stuff like that was sort of like a
alternative like twist yes mirror mirror
was kind of like not parody
but over the top like it wasn't a
a true to form remake and so this will
be like
the story period just live instead of
animated and like why so many like why
did we i guess
they think it's a story worth telling no
it feels like they're like really messy
and like can't decide how they want to
tell snow white's story in a modern era
like i feel like they really brought
lion king beauty and the beast into the
21st century with these live actions
and maleficent like they just really
have been like killing it and then the
snow white department
i just feel like they need to
restructure like it's just kind of messy
but i think that this would is that
so this is like the official retelling
of snow white yes i don't think they're
even like thinking about
mirror mirror and snow white in the
huntsman but do they not see how that's
confusing for the consumer
uh they don't care about you they made
that clear so clear
so crystal clear crystal mirror mirror
on the wall
okay so it's snow white is that the one
with the
dwarves is that the word that's the word
in that feels like that needs to be
changed i don't know i think it will be
changed
yeah the seven dwarves yeah sounds weird
i don't know why
um i bet you on my life like i could not
name them okay
there's definitely grumpy okay i have a
leg up because of descendants
i don't okay so this is someone who saw
snow white when they were a child and
like never bothered to
follow up on her story grumpy i know
that for sure
you can relate and i want to say there's
a sleepy yep
and that is you know kind of confusing i
also think there's a stinky no okay
okay grumpy sleepy
sneezy and easy honestly like that's
literally all i know can you name the
rest of the four
no now i'm like those are the obvious i
was waiting for sneezy sneezy is not
obvious no grumpy and sleepy
happy okay
okay that's okay let me pull up a list
though
and before you do that i just wanted to
say that i'm actually really looking
forward to this new
concert special coming out on peacock on
friday the miley cyrus pride event
where she just sings like you know gay
anthems with
special guests because i saw a clip of
her and marin morris
performing i don't remember but it was
just like a classic mom it's a song
and i'm just really excited about it
because i nothing
miley does nothing better than covers
like she's a cover queen yeah and
all the people that they're bringing in
i think like casey musgraves mayor
morris
i'm really excited okay here are the
seven dwarves
dopey you should have known that okay i
guess is he the one like on
like drugs can look at disney things
like with a dark eye he's the only dwarf
who does not have a beard he's accident
prone and mute
with happy explaining that's another one
happy that he has simply never tried to
speak
so they call him so what wouldn't that
make him like mutey yeah
okay i think the dwarves are gonna have
to be re-imagined this is very offensive
like
dopey sneezy because he has
extraordinarily powerful sneezes
bashful very shy and kind-hearted that's
me
sleepy speaks for himself happy
jovial dwarf grumpy grumpy
and doc he's the leader of the dwarves
he wears glasses and often mixes up his
words
yeah i just feel like the whole dwarves
community
needs to be rewritten because it's just
not very 2021 friendly like the way they
describe them
i think i don't know if the word dwarves
is appropriate like i just think
i trust disney to bring the story of
snow white into the 21st century yeah
and that was from wikipedia by the way
um so
did you hear what i said about the prime
peacock special sorry that's like a fun
thing to do if you're on your retro
party maybe you guys want to stay in
like like watch and like drink yeah but
i don't
think that we'll like stay in and watch
that but i will just probably watch that
at some point
in the mood for a concert dvd
i love a concert like it's the kind of
dvd like that's what it is
and we're living in an age where we're
getting like access to so many because
of all these streaming services like
i will never say no to watching like
reputation stadium tour
the beyonce document like i part of me
katy perry
like i will never it's my favorite thing
to watch yeah it's truly so enjoyable
it really is are you ready for our next
story
sure what were you gonna make no i
wasn't gonna say anything we're gonna
make fun because i was working on my
segway
no i did i say one word i'm working mom
i'm working on my sideways
have you ever ridden a segway the one
with the like yeah
i don't know i did a segway tour in
jerusalem
and i have to say like it was the most
fun i've ever had as someone who's so
[ __ ] lazy
these walking tours are just not for me
but it's like a thing in israel where
you do like segway tours
and it's actually really scary um to get
off of a segway like you have to balance
completely right the riding is super
easy
so fun highly recommend getting a segway
even though they're illegal on the
streets of new york
thank you this story is brought to you
by segways that's why i know all the
pedestrian laws
say i know that you can't ride a segway
and i know that i was right this morning
more people are riding scooters yeah i
think we should become a
scooter-friendly city
i completely agree we birded in austin
we had
so much fun it was hysterical and it's a
really efficient way of getting around
for a city that like
from north to south is and that doesn't
cover that many miles yeah i just don't
know
if how you would do it is on the
sidewalk or on the street
because the bike lanes we have so many
that's true nobody respects the bike
lane so i would actually be
like scared to go on a scooter in a bike
lane because people do not respect the
bike lanes
i everyone i know respects bike lanes
well you know nice people but
hanging out with but i'm not saying my
friends i'm saying i see on the street
like
nobody respects a bike lane they pull
over in a cab into a bike lane they open
the door they don't even look for a
cyclist like
justice actually for the bikers in new
york they literally keep this city
running and literally nobody has respect
for the lanes
yeah i don't know about all that no for
sure i know about some of it
but i don't know i'm not saying the
people who like leisurely ride their
bikes to like their corporate offices
i'm saying like people who ride like
delivery keeping new york running
keeping new york running we need to
respect the bike lanes i agree but if
you're coming out of a taxi this one's
happened to me in a biker crash and
oh my god i felt so horrible everyone oh
my god it's horrible i've seen it happen
in cabs you're just supposed that's why
do you remember that ad campaign
look and the two o's in the word look
were eyes
do you remember that yeah that's like
the whole campaign like just when you
get out
on the curb always look for a biker okay
but like when you're in
the car before you open the door it's
hard to like lean out and see
no you look in the back window oh i
guess it's there's so many things
happening of course
no but people just need to be more
conscious yeah because
honestly if it happens to you once it
will never happen you'll be scared it's
so it's the worst feeling it's so
upsetting
okay next story finally it's time carl
massive thanks the nfl for matching his
100 thousand dollar donation
to the trevor project he says you're
saving lives how do you know that they
match the donation yes on monday las
vegas raiders player carl nasa became
the first active nfl player to come out
as gay
and now he's thanking the nfl and fans
who donated to the trevor project to
support suicide prevention
among lgbtq youth the 28 year old las
vegas raiders defensive end made sports
history monday when he came out to the
public as gay
making him the first active nfl player
to do so with the announcement he
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
the trevor project
explaining that he feels an immense
responsibility to help in any way he can
yeah and nfl announced that they would
match the donation this was like
so fabulous because i think a lot of
people reference michael sam
as the first gay football player which
he was but he didn't come out until
after he was
retired or no longer played in the nfl
and i think that like you know
the nfl is very much like toxic
masculinity like you know dudes locker
room talk bro yeah
and so to come out is probably really
really hard and i have a lot of respect
for him and i never even heard of him
but he's my new favorite player
and he's very hot like none that it's
matters but he's
just for reference like in case anyone
was wondering he's very handsome yes
very very handsome looks like we're
raiders fans now oh 100
100 gotta meet up with carl
no this is a really great story and i'm
sure he's changing a lot of lives for
kids who
play football who who might not see how
they can be all of these things
oh what was that documentary i was
watching oh um
the aaron hernandez documentary yeah
there was
a player in that documentary who
no longer played but he knew he was gay
when he was playing on it might have
been
his high school or he was in the nfl i
can't remember but he really like
articulated perfectly like why it's
so hard to be gay in those types of
environments and how like i'm sure there
are
plenty of other players who never came
out while they were in the nfl
yeah but like it's just i have a lot of
respect it's a very courageous thing to
do
and carl you have two number one fans
yeah great story great story and love
raising money love that the nfl
is publicly supporting but like
you know it's like what happens in
locker rooms is like really where
like the concern i probably comes from
it's like
the nfl front facing of the 100 000 to
the nfl is like literally a dollar to us
like it's not a big deal
i just and he said like his teammates
have been very supportive of the
management and like
that's probably where it's scary to come
out like within like your teammates that
you never know how other people are
going to react so yeah
i'm just wishing everyone the best
totally are you ready for our next story
which is a little
ice cream drama is it the ice cream
drama that's brought to you by
ipvanish yes it is wow that's
absolutely nuts welcome
what today's episode is sponsored by
ipv6
wow today's episode is sponsored by
ipvanish what is ipvanish a virtual
private network vpn for short
a vpn is a super important tool that
helps you safely browse the internet
you can use a vpn on your computer
tablet phone even things like a fire
stick when you're streaming media
when you use a vpn all of your data
becomes encrypted what you're reading
searching watching whatever it is that
you're doing
and that's important because what you're
doing on the internet is absolutely
nobody else's business but yours
ipvanish helps you remain anonymous and
secure on the internet
for listeners of our show ipvanish is
offering an incredible 65
off just 3.49 for a month or 31.49 cents
for the year
here's everything you get with ipvanish
anonymous i p addresses which means your
personal ip address cannot be tracked
you can circumvent any online censorship
they have more than 1500 servers in 70
plus locations
i used ipvanish when i was in the
british virgin islands trying to get
access to the harry and megan interview
which was not available
in britain which is weird because that's
where harry's is from
and i use ipvanish and it works
seamlessly you also get protection when
you use public wi-fi
and 24 7 support you can email chat with
them even call them
so go to ipvanish.comtoast to claim your
65
savings they have plans starting at just
3.49 or 31.49 a year
this is the time to sign up with our
discount and their current promotional
offerings
you can get a vpn for 65 off their usual
offering
ipvanish is the best of the best rated
4.7 out of five on
trustpilot and that's with more than
6000 reviews
remember it's ipvanish.com toast to get
the deal and start protecting yourself
online
thank you for that claudia you're
welcome okay next story the dip and dots
ceo
is accused of blackmailing his
ex-girlfriend and sending revenge porn
to her mother
this is so upsetting because i love
dippin dots
the ceo of dip and dot's ice cream is
being accused of sending revenge porn of
his ex-girlfriend to multiple people
including her mother
according to a civil complaint filed in
oklahoma disgusting
disgusting scott fisher is being sued by
amanda brown that she dated from early
2019 to late 2020 the lawsuit alleges in
the complaint obtained by people brown
alleges that fisher frequently solicited
private sexual messages from brown
throughout the course of their
relationship brown additionally alleges
that fisher would take his own explicit
photos of her
sometimes consensually and sometimes
surreptitiously
brown also alleged that fisher
frequently conditioned continued
financial support to brown
based on her furnishing him with
explicit photos
after the couple split brown alleged
that fisher sent explicit images of her
to other people including her own mother
she also alleged that he threatened to
send them out to more people in an
attempt to control her actions
this is so sick what a freak first of
all
second of all does he still work for the
company
it says dippin.ceo that's so upsetting
because honestly like i cannot support a
brand like that but like i love dippin
dots
when's the last time you even had dippin
dots they sell them at the grocery store
and like
any time i'm at an amusement park which
isn't that much when's the last time you
really had dippin dots
what is this like the sats stop asking
me [ __ ] questions
like years doesn't mean i still don't
like it
no i know but did i say i have it all
the time i just said i'd like it
no but i i liked it not too but i just
feel like it's not really a new york
city thing
sometimes you're like such an
investigator it's really annoying like
just let me speak
like you have to like interrogate and
interrogate
like the one discrepancy in my story
like i wasn't
like i was gonna never mind all i was
saying was that i really like dippin
dots there are a lot of things i really
like but i don't do
every day doesn't mean i don't like it i
never said you needed to do it every day
in order to like it
well then why did you why did you break
up the frequency in which i consumed
different dots
because i just said i like love gibbon
because he's like really what does last
time you have
to point out that it like won't be hard
for you to forsake different knots if
need be
well if i okay here let me explain it to
you
i've never not sorry i've never been in
the presence of dippin dots and not
eaten them
okay so anytime i come across whether
it's in a grocery store
there used to be a store in the city in
flat iron if i'm at an amusement park
maybe i'll
go to amusement park this summer like i
don't know i'm just saying like i've
been
in the presence of dippin dots many many
times and i've always eaten it
okay so you're a big dippin knots fan
yeah but honestly i need dippin dots to
release a statement that they don't
stand by this kind of misogynistic
disgusting exploitive
exploitative behavior agreed in order
for me to continue being
a lifelong fan of the brand maybe i
don't need it at the frequency that my
sister wishes i did
but i'm still a fan thank you for that
statement the clarification was my
pleasure are you ready for a little food
news that's a little more exciting
um yeah i just wanted to double check
because i got here like a little late
and i didn't really get to raise by the
stories are we going to talk about casey
neistat's new man
we already talked about that newer man
she's a new new man she's not with that
man anymore the doctor
she's with a writer now he posted a
photo a polaroid of them like
sitting on her she's sitting on his lap
giving him a kiss on the cheek he's a
writer i don't know what he writes
but his caption was you know doing
everything in my power not to write
about her
okay she shared a rumored her rumor new
beau shared a sweet photo of
her saying trying like hell not to write
about her his name is cole and he's a
writer i don't know if he's like a
songwriter i think he writes like poems
which is so romantic or books sure where
do you
where did you i can't believe i missed
all of this yeah oh my god like i'm so
sorry and they were in the city
they were yeah they were spotted after
walking around new york city together
and then the confirmation came on his
instagram yesterday oh he's cute
yeah his name is cole and he's a writer
so we're just what kind of writer
no i know it's very vague he has like 30
000 instagram followers so he's like
successful where is that how we measure
success where did you see writer was it
in his
bio uh like a page six like i saw the
the instagram stuff
stuff go down and then i saw um a bunch
of news outlets write it up and refer to
him as a writer
and it's all also in his instagram bio
interesting yeah so again i feel like
he's an rm drake
he's like a quotes writer like a quotes
writer inspirational writer that's just
what i think i have no idea
because when someone says writer it's
like that's not author
right it's not songwriter right so it's
actually like a vague word
it is an influencer you know sort of
when you think of writer what do you
think of three
two one writer girl but this is writer
boy oh my god no and she's right or girl
so it's literally a
match made in heaven yeah maybe they
couldn't collab mm-hmm that's really
sweet
yeah i like that she's just playing the
field i feel like she went from that
long relationship
with her band mate which was just not
the right fit
and then into another long relationship
immediately with rustin and i feel like
i'm glad she's playing the field like
girl live your life you're
literally one of the most famous singers
in the world like
party like go meet go meet some guys
totally she looks really happy in these
pictures
yeah but i do need her to release some
new music like
she's she is going she's getting her
magazine interview that it's coming i
think it's coming this year it's just
time
you can you can know that it's coming it
is time
what else is coming is a krispy kreme
ipo
oh you want to invest in something you
can believe in
krispy kreme looks to raise as much as
640 million dollars through
ipo well they got 50 committed from me
i believe in the brand the donut chain
is looking to sell stock for 21 to 24
a share so you could get two shares
maybe i'll spring for three
exciting wait this is so exciting
because you want to know why
like i feel first of all i just love
krispy kreme like i just think they're
such a
fabulous brand their product at the end
of the day like
the cream always rises literally the
krispy kreme rises further
and krispy kreme throughout the years
has always just been like the best donut
they've never shied away from what makes
them great
and i really respect that as a brand
like even you know moving into the 21st
century with all these you know donuts
are bad for you like they don't [ __ ]
care and i love that about them
and i will be purchasing some stock when
does this uh ipo happen
um this year they're they're getting
ready and as we saw in the wework
documentary
things take time they have to go on they
have to do their showcase or whatever
it's called
yeah like their little dance song and
dance they have to put together the big
file
i want to be in those meetings like i
want to know why i should
purchase krispy kreme because i'm going
to yeah no it's exciting news i'm
excited i wonder what it's oh it's going
to trade under the ticker
d-n-u-t d-net oh that's these nuts
honestly they should have thought about
that before
because that was the first thing that
came to mind like i get it like donut
but like
where's the uh again like these notes
whatever i'll be purchasing three shares
of these nuts um
when the time is right because you want
to know why like americans
we're like what they say like the most
obese country in the world we look this
up recently i'm actually not the most
but like they say like michelle obama
always used to say like we are a
childhood obesity problem we do
we have an obesity problem but we did
confirm recently that we're not number
one
oh thank god but we still have the
problem and you know i just think that's
not going away any time soon so i
actually think financially it makes a
lot of sense to purchase krispy kreme
d nut chairs yeah these nuts and you
have to invest in what you can believe
in
and i believe in these nuts
um yeah no i agree that's crazy
i endorse you investing
yeah if you want to like then mommy like
50 oh you could invest
on my behalf yeah of course i can't
guarantee you'll see a return but
interesting well also it hasn't happened
yet so everyone
just calm down but we're just giving you
like a little pre-finance news a little
sneak peek a little taste of these nuts
okay our fifth and final story is some
real
biz news a little biz news
because as i'm sure you've heard it's
been amazon prime day for three days
oh my god the marketing is actually
really starting to bother me and i have
a conspiracy theory about prime day but
i'll let you finish
and the prime day sales have surpassed
11 billion dollars
topping record cyber monday levels so
okay then i'm i don't know if i'm right
but i've participated in
prime day pretty much every year there's
always something like i want to get but
i just think it's success stupid to
spend money
i never prepare well enough for pride
like do a
total inventory of what i need in my
life and wait for prime day like
i'm always a few years ago i bought a
roomba
literally one of the worst purchases i
ever made like no offense that robot was
dumb as [ __ ] like
he didn't know like what a wall was and
like what a corner wasn't he was always
getting stuck
in like crevices i just hated it and
like it really did nothing
and like he couldn't even send it to
himself home back to the base which so i
have to like
get out of bed like go pick up the room
but like it was just a torture chamber
but i've bought a lot of things on prime
day like you know i bought in the
beginning like some alexas whatever
and i just don't really feel like the
prices are
that great like i feel like a few weeks
before
prime day like all the prices of popular
like tech items go up
and then they like drop back to their
original price like that's just the way
that i feel
yeah i don't know if that's true but i
go on and i'm like why is this [ __ ]
still expensive it's supposed to be
prime day
i just don't really feel like the
savings are as big as they market them
to be
now i have no proof of that i'm just
saying it's a feeling no i just feel
like prime day
the only thing i bought this prime day
was a bathing suit from rach parcell
and i didn't see was it on amazon yeah
she like posted like some of her amazon
oh and then
raised parcel brand new baby she posted
some amazon fashion friends and she put
it
in great amazon fashion she posted suits
that i absolutely had to have and i
bought it regardless but i didn't even
see a sale price reflected
you know i just like prime day is like
kind of just like a marketing gimmick
like we're going to call a prime day and
we're just going to keep reminding you
that you should shop on amazon
yeah but see prime day has also been
like beneficial for me in other ways
like the prime day concert last
well two years ago taylor swift
scissor jubilee but like that was
that was good i appreciated that there
was no concert this year and i just feel
like they inflate the prices just so
that they can decrease them and
call it a sale and that's not a sale
that's a gimmick
yeah i agree i'm kind of out on prime
day i kind of am too
and don't get me wrong we're clearly
alone in that yeah
i love like amazon like i i know
everyone's like it's the big bad amazon
but like i'm totally here for it um like
the convenience and ease at which
my life moves thanks to amazon i'm
forever grateful for
i just don't really believe in this
whole prime day thing i'm just i'm
suspicious i really am
and i think i'm on to something and now
that i've put that in your brain i think
you guys like next prime day we'll see
what i was talking about
yeah i agree i and i just did not
prepare well no and the only real
discounts that they offer are on their
own products like amazon echo dot
because they can't do that i got a
kindle yesterday
that oh you know what i kind of wanted
like a new fancy candle i should have
done that
i should look into like what the newer
kindles are i really like mine
i told him to get like the newest one
and that if he doesn't really use it
i'll take it
because i just want to see what else is
out there but i love mine so much it's
been so good to me i know and like it
works completely it works so great it's
so
light you know yeah um well were those
the fastest stories that you needed to
know
the fastest stories that you need to
know i feel like you need to know them
i'm excited to dive into your toasters
which is our advice segment if you're
ever
looking for any sort of advice on
something work related relationship
related
we are here for you deartoasters
gmail.com we will always keep it
anonymous and if you've written to us
recently and we've
read your quandary on air and you want
to update us with how things went
we would absolutely love to hear from
you today we have one update and then
two other submissions
so let's dive into deer toasters brought
to you by
scentbird have you ever had someone come
up to you and say you smell amazing what
perfume are you wearing
whatever scent you may be wearing you
have good taste and you know it but your
great taste
is also expensive and you end up with a
shelf full of half used bottles
with sun bird we found a way to have
great taste and mix up our fragrance
routine without breaking the bank
scentbird is a fragrant subscription
service that gives you the opportunity
to shop from over 600 brands it is a
flexible subscription so you can skip
any month without penalties
sandberg lets you choose a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises they have perfumes and
colognes
plus a lot of unisex options and they
carry sickening brands like prada gucci
versace
they have just like tons and tons of
brands
ones you might have heard of ones you
might not have heard of like confessions
of a rebel
i got a bunch of their scents like
sickeningly stunning so
don't be don't be shy like try different
ones um and some of the bottles that
they have on there can cost anywhere
from 150 to 500
but they are charging you 16 a month and
with our code
you can get 11 on your first month so
the exclusive offer is 30
off your first month today that's only
11 for your first fragrance go to
scentbird.com and use the code toast for
30
off your first month again that's
s-c-e-n-t bird.com
to try your first perfumer cologne for
just eleven dollars
sign-ons smell amazing
all right let's dive into your toasters
hey claudia and jackie my favorite
sisters
thank you i'm caught contacting you guys
today about a current dilemma i am in
my best friend chloe recently got
married and had a wonderful wedding it
was super fun and got a little wild at
the reception
chloe is a friend and bridesmaid named
mandy manny was always joking about
getting with chloe's younger brother
who's five years younger
while she's always joked about it to
chloe chloe has always said no way
not allowed while it's been joking tone
for both sides i truly think chloe meant
hands off my brother after the
after chloe and her new husband left the
wedding mandy went home with chloe's
brother
the next morning she asked me to pick
her up from his house and tried to tell
me all about it
i told her i didn't want to know now the
bride is on the honeymoon and has no
clue about what happened and all the
bridesmaids are assuming that they slept
together
so my question is what do i do do i
pretend i know nothing and not tell my
best friend
do i inform her about it when she gets
back from her honeymoon i haven't been
talking to mandy and fear she will
ask me to keep it a secret should i talk
to mandy about it encourage her to tell
chloe i don't want to get involved but i
also don't want to lie to my friends
please help a sister out sincerely a
struggling toaster okay so basically
like she needs to know
if she should tell the bride that one of
the bridesmaids [ __ ] her brother
i would say um stay out of it if the
bride asks
you directly don't lie to her no
i don't agree what because what makes it
worse is like if she finds out and then
like all of her bridesmaids knew and
nobody told her like that's so hurtful
only one bridesmaid knows for sure no no
she said all the bridesmaids are stupid
they slept together
yeah they're they're assuming but they
don't know for sure because they didn't
pick her up the next morning yeah but
like if none of that it's all them think
something went on and nobody told her
like that's even more hurtful
not only did like your friend betray you
then like all of your other friends did
nothing
i don't know i don't i don't know
i think she's just like a betrayer like
maybe it's an anonymous note kind of
thing
no i don't think so because i don't
really think she needs to know like
she's newly married she's so happy
mandy slept with her brother like it's
not a huge deal well
like either they're gonna keep sleeping
together and be in a relationship which
is sweet or it's never gonna happen
again which
like solves the issue also i do think
the bride like being so
like bent out of [ __ ] i mean i don't
have a brother so i don't really know
what it's like but i do think it's like
not that big of a deal
but she's made it clear like she doesn't
want it so like now what does everyone
do but like it's not that big of a deal
i think like really truly
and also like i'm assuming the bride is
say 28
i'm just gonna take a guess and the
brother is 23. like
he's as long as he's like legal
of legal age and these are two
consenting adults like sure i'm sure the
sister didn't want it but i think in
general like
it's not that big of a deal i think if
anything you should just
if you want to do something encourage
mandy to go talk to the bride like
it's her mistake she's gotta deal with
it sure
because you want to be a good friend
yeah i guess i can't really put myself
in this position because like
we don't have a brother yeah that we
would feel this way if
like i i can't i feel like so many times
people are weird about brothers
no i feel like friends are excited when
like a friend like hooks up with their
brother
some people yes that's like ideal like
maybe you hope they'll get married yeah
but sometimes people are weird about
brothers like they are
i think it's weird if she's weird i know
but we don't have a brother like we
really can't say that
yeah i would i would encourage mandy to
like
be the grown-up it's really not your
problem like you didn't do anything
wrong
like now you have this pit when you just
were a good bridesmaid
but i also feel like everyone needs to
just take a step back and like look and
gain some perspective and realize like
it wasn't a murder
like yeah i'm not it's not that serious
it's okay
it's gonna be okay no that's actually a
really good point even if the bride is a
little peeved for a few days like she'll
[ __ ] get over it
yeah i mean i guess like the most
similar thing i can think of is like at
my wedding
and i think maybe at your wedding too
like a lot of our male cousins i hooked
up with our friends which we were so
exciting and maybe that's the kind of
sisters we would be if we had a brother
but not everyone is like that maybe if
you had a brother that
you were passionate about you would know
what it's like
but you don't also we do have a half
brother
and i would be so excited oh my god i
wouldn't
that would make someone my sister i
really think you guys are blowing this
out of proportion
yeah no but see again that's how we
would be like if anyone came
and wanted to like marry our half
brother like we would
i would die like that'd be so great like
we would all be so close we could have
barbecues
a hundred percent but again tell her
about the barbecue some people are weird
yeah why don't you paint a picture for
her barbecues couples trips no because
he's like i don't want to be his
girlfriend yeah and the brother's like i
was just trying to get supposed to be
like
you guys this is not like it's really
not that serious it's not
serious so true all right next up hi
claudia and jackie
long time listener here i need y'all's
advice on a situation with my sister
here's the situation
my sister has been severely editing the
shape
the shape size of her head in pictures
for the last three years and i've let
this issue go on for three years too
long
my sister is beautiful so i don't know
what her complex but her head size is
all about
she always insists pictures of us or
groups are taken on her phone and then
she will only send the pictures where
she has edited the size of her head
i think my biggest and most selfish
issue with her edits is that my head is
already bigger
and she goes on to make her smaller so
i'm
so i'm left looking like mega mind also
on the rare chance that pictures are
taken on someone else's phone people
will pose the original and she will post
the edit
it's so obvious but she doesn't think
anybody knows now i appreciate a little
face tune here and there but hers has
gone way too far my sister and i are
pretty close
but we've never really talked about our
body image or anything like that so i'm
needing advice on how to talk to her
about editing faux pas
my sister will be getting married this
year and i don't want her to alter all
of her pictures
please give me the best sisterly advice
you have i want my sister to be
confident because she doesn't need to
edit the way she looks
i'm looking forward to hearing what you
all have to say thanks a million this is
a very interesting
thing because i'm very pro facetune like
i'm the type of person it's like
you know facetune can give you the body
you want like and i really don't feel
like there's anything wrong with that
but i agree when it comes to like
wedding photos like you really just want
to look like yourself and also if she's
impacting the way you look like that's
really not cool
yeah i feel like i can't relate to the
head of it all
but but i make my arms we can like place
ourselves in this position like
sometimes we'll take a group picture
some people want to
you know tinker with it and then also
like sometimes
other people suffer because of it like
you can't take from some you can't give
to something without taking from
somewhere else no you can't
take from something without giving to
something else
and that's honestly the balance that is
facetune
right so everything like it really needs
to be a group
effort if there's a group photo face
tuned but i if one of our sisters was
like facetuning to the point of like
embarrassment i would say something no
and sometimes actually like we've had
that in the past where like someone will
post a picture and we'll post this it
happened to me like
you guys will screenshot my instagram
and be like you're crazy like
delete this and we do it to the other
like we check each other what will
happen is
someone will edit themselves like in the
picture say it's two people like really
not look at the other person because
like that's not their problem but then
they post a picture and the other person
looks so
deformed yeah and it
you lose credibility when you post it
like that no 100 so like i actually
think it's
we have a good type of relationship like
we're constantly checking each other
like it seems like she's close with her
sister they haven't broached this topic
yet but i think that you can and i think
you need to just be like
be kind because it's obviously an
insecurity but be like you're so
beautiful if my head's bigger than yours
what what are you hiding like honestly i
don't really feel like i can give
appropriate advice until i see the size
of both the heads like i
i just need to i feel like i feel like
it's one of those things like you think
your head is so big and like nobody
notices you know
yeah what is it what even is a big head
like like a conan
like i need reference yeah no it's it's
weird like i have a big everything else
like i would love a big head you know
finally balance this thing out
honestly just talk to her just talk to
her sisters are cool like even if she
gets upset like
and sometimes people need tough love and
if like you don't want all of her
wedding photos to be like you know the
like curvy the um warped
yeah what's it the pillar in the
background is like it's like turnt yeah
dancing no and also um i think the real
travesty here is like her posting edited
ones while the non-edited ones are
floating around the internet horrible
and you just need to be a good sister
and tell her like that's really not
appropriate internet conduct
yeah and once the original is out there
like don't you dare
post an edited one yeah like that's just
yeah that's the rules of engagement um
all right this third one is an update
hello stevie queens as you may recall
i'm the girl who didn't drink her coffee
before taking her new man to the airport
therefore resulted in an accidental and
horribly embarrassing i love you
well ladies after much patience and many
other airport drop off drop-offs i'm
officially his girlfriend
we made it couldn't have done it without
my stings make sure all the toasters
know a situation chip can turn into a
relationship
even if you say i love you in one month
thanks so much for your help oh we just
love a happy ending
we really do so you know what that was
maybe the universe's way of telling you
like you
actually maybe did love this man like of
course i accidentally told like my
teacher i loved her i didn't actually
love her
but you know this could have been like
kismet yeah that's beautiful we're going
to have to start a happy now
that's our show anything else you want
to talk about relive recall
no only content update for me is i'm
reading malibu rising
so good oh yeah i'll finish it today
yeah it's really really good you're
gonna like it it's more similar to
evelyn hugo than it is to daisy jones
and the six there's so much thank god
there's so much crossover it's like it's
really crazy
so i'm taking a long flight tomorrow
i'll probably start there oh
enjoy yeah excited so i have nothing
else to update i just have like meetings
meetings meetings
and we got to get to it so i think
that's our show thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past life stories that you
need to show every monday through friday
and youtube so if you're watching this
on youtube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
morning shows leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
hope you guys have an amazing hump day
and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye